[Music]
what's it like to be back here in st.
Louis I always love it there I always
loved the city in fact we come here all
the time three to four times a year it's
good to be back I think last time I
played here was not very good certainly
it was pretty forgettable so I'm just
looking forward to doing better than I
did last time in the u.s. championship
with the order being rapid and blitz
before the classical the fields gonna be
quite a bit different certainly doesn't
say last year one of the other way
around I mean I live here so I don't
know if I'm really back but I haven't
played here in a while I took a long
break to train after Paris after the
Grantchester were there and so I haven't
really been at the board except for
training since then and I'm gonna be
back facing the same guy so it's going
to be an interesting feeling I'm looking
forward to the games I hope that I can
enjoy the games the tournament and
hopefully come with some good chess as
well every July August I'm just looking
forward to coming back I mean I always
get in a few days early so initially
it's quite relaxed but as you get closer
to the tournament the butterfly study
last year I played here for the first
time in my life I was quite impressed
with the level of the tournament and and
I'm happy to be back here but your first
time here in the same phase is very
interesting but I play the first time us
tournament in my just life first time
yeah it's always a pleasure to be here
and you know I just want to show my best
chest basically and observe that's its
back from good st. Louis is one of this
places close to my heart I love being
here I always tell my friends so I go
imagine a city where you have this
fantastic Street and there you have the
Chess Club and there you have a museum
for chess and you have a shelf in this
museum where you can buy cool stuff and
you get to play there so I love being
here
you